there's gonna be two to three minutes of
gag reel that'll be um dis good so no
one seen the film no one seen the guy
grill don't see anything can you give us
a moment that you think might be on the
gag reel from set oh my god well any
time Pratt's around then again I say
that that the stand out nonsense player
lately has been Hemsworth and also just
the the journey that Thor goes on in
infinity war and Beyond is to me just
it's just amazing you know and he's a
all that so always love the Guardians
you know anytime that I did anything
with with Rudd I think that's probably
gonna play pretty well if there's ever a
chance that Paltrow and I are and
Favreau happened to be within a hundred
miles of each other that always works
it could be a keep damn well be anything
and as The Godfather yes do you have a
go to must have Marvel Cinematic
Universe fill of all the 1819 that this
is now Wow well I'm a bit of an origins
guy so I would say watch the first in
any series because that's that's really
the one where it's like it's like a
newborn foal it's a little shaky on the
legs and then you're like how does it
how was it walking so quick so yeah the
first of any of them can to wrap up last
question we've heard great things over
the last day or two about off sets
lunches parties at hosts by Robert how
tell us a little bit about alright I
used to call myself the head of the
acting department then now I was given
the name The Godfather or the Bob father
I've heard that said too but now what I
am is a very comfortable and lazy event
coordinator that's essentially what I do
now so bar mitzvahs parties weddings
after parties and certainly production
lunches that's something that I special
gogoat was served there was a ghost
where did you hear this yeah and I'm
trying to think why oh because uh the
chef said you know sometimes you were in
Georgia she said you know I have a
backyard and I could probably roast a
whole pig but it's a whole thing I got
to dig a hole and I was like geez I was
like well we're gonna need that and then
it just seemed a little less brutal but
even stranger that there was a cloven
hoofed animal brought to it we got very
medieval that day I'll tell you that
much
and I'm told the goats name was known
the goat had a pretty nice life before
it was ended prematurely for our needs
look the whole world should be heading
towards being vegetarian but until then
like you know don't give me any guff
once the things already been off I mean
it if I got offed I would rather be
served while I still tasted good from
the trail it looks like the two you have
some fun interaction banter what was it
like working together
it was tiring man you know benadryl diva
and she says again does he I had a lot
of it I was making two films at once
right and in that we were making two
films together at the film that we were
making together in London I had a very
Oh Riko whoop so then I got to Avengers
and they were like we want to cut your
hair and I would felt really
passionately about the London project
project and I said well guys listen if
there's any way we can work around not
cutting my hair cuz I don't want to
jeopardize my work in London they said
sure we'll just make it that Spider Man
has really long hair so in this film I
have the most ridiculously crafted
stupid haircut of all time I was
actually joking but that is it a lot
reveal about your hair it's in the tree
I saw in the trade offs I've got all
that just looks ridiculous charming I
look like I've got some weird audience
there's a very big Disney when it's that
will like that Jack and you might get an
endorsement sorry I spent on a real ron
maybe I'll do like a L'Oreal commercial
laughter this film comes out that sounds
amazing I mean I would like to say the
bonding agent is Thanos a gay Josh
Brolin greatest awesomest actor but you
know there's so many talented people and
there's so many different characters
putting them all together and
characteristics together it just it
makes it fun and it's like it's just a
roller coaster ride where we find Winter
Soldier you vitamin Wakanda hanging out
I guess recently it was also visited by
Sam we go down to the beach we hang out
down by the beach and then you know they
kind of settled some of their old
pastime you know kind of struggles and
then here we are we're in a yacht we go
down to Trinidad and Tobago come back up
here Cuba next thing you know we here
for press dun da da and please role in
the film obviously because you see in
the trailer yeah tell us what what kind
of means in this film well I feel where
you left off in the last movie as
wakanda's open up their borders they've
agreed to share their vibranium and
you're gonna get to see what that means
in this world oh you know world's never
seen that before and vibranium life for
some vibranium and it's here so long and
glassy I know
I have never movie
danos yes yeah bring it down
waited wait wait the conversation down
villain awful guy tell us about famous
that was a sociopath that Wow he's
reckless with his power he's wrecked me
no well he I don't know if he's reckless
cuz he's very calculated he knows what
he's after calculated now I know why he
got the way he is a regular guy like
everybody else puts his pants on one leg
at a time no no I don't think what's
really cool about tennis is that mix of
like intellect and brawn so he's really
smart you can't just think of him as
just a mad brawler he's you know he's
great like that and that's what's at
verbal he's got those stones
he's gonna slow so royal campaign purple
hey some now tell us about the working
with Russo brothers how are they working
with it
that's great you know the really fun
part about working with the Russo's is
is two of them so you get two different
perspectives but with the same idea at
hand you know they always get together
and talk about what they want their
direction to be and then they come to us
and kind of guide us in the direction of
what the overall story of the movie is
because in these movies the scope is so
large you can get lost at times you know
if you're not brought in by them and
every morning to figure out what it is
and they're they're very good about
keeping actors in the loop telling you
where you are what's going on and what's
happening after which if most actors
have you give them a beginning and an
end their job is to fill in the middle
and they're very good at it
the whole stuff feeling like yeah yeah
yeah and they bring you soup good soup
is good soup
good soup and there was a ghost right
someone else's they want to talk about
the bill this is for our cats not huh
yeah we wanted air Winston and our DJ
chef Robert Downey jr. chef this amazing
woman amazing cooks Chris got a goat she
dug a hole in the middle of a parking
lot and she roasted her go oh ho goat
sounds really Lois
and she's like for the crew it was goat
it was goat everywhere was shakes good
girl salad good no it was goat
sandwiches there was leftover goat for a
goat salad the next day feel about being
a part of this milestone in the MCU
grateful like this is a milestone in
cinema yeah feel like no other film has
been able to culminate a ten-year span
eighteen movies and two films I'm really
excited to see this movie yeah on one
like I just I'm looking I'm talking
about I realize we haven't seen the
movie it's like it's gonna be you know
it's gonna be amazing they're right you
shouldn't because everybody should see
it at the right time and when it drops
the Internet's gonna break all the great
internet avenges 2018 check your neck
Wi-Fi out is sure you ready for the nose
sure he's ready anything worse man ready
ready ready ready Joe plus it's super
competitive and aggressive on set and
Marvel has really managed to foster sort
of you know a range amongst a different
team no no just with everyone you know
like the trailers will squash together
in the truck
okay the Train the problem being worries
about it I so tired
you know you've been we've been moved
their big movies right but yeah they
usually movies usually feel so small or
big or whatever but
I remember one day driving in in the
morning and it was still dark and I
thought gosh II and now we're shooting
in middle of nowhere in the wilderness
and yet we're driving down into a town
and then I realized that it was just the
trailers because all of us all of our
trailers were there lit up ready for us
just and there was none teams trailers
and our doubles trailers there's like
three of each of us running around and
there's 30 of us tell me some fun moment
either on screen or off screen that you
guys can relate to well I mean on screen
well we were just talking about earlier
is this there's just like this hilarious
moment where lots of people have to say
difficult words and Paul's constantly
making jokes about everything on and off
set and when we move from being on set
we then move to a tent and we're all
like this gathered a circle and all we
do is just continue to just laugh and
make jokes and I have a good time and
and you were confused that you were
allowed to laugh or something yeah
because we were just breaking it so it's
really just out of you as the jokester
right is that well Paul's the jokes are
loose Paul and Ruffalo are like a
married couple
no one that's true they're like The Odd
Couple they're constantly bickering yeah
about real things and speaking it used
about it like yeah it's pretty it's
pretty entertaining that sounds yeah
film that too but not on the internet so
where do we find your characters real
briefly quickly where do we find your
characters at the beginning of infinity
horse you find Sheree and her lab
working away
and wondering why her brother has
invited his purple friends that do you
open do starvin change the weather and
who are these people that's what she's
thinking you find us in Edinburgh yes
Hey in Scotland were in Edinburgh and
she is a fugitive from the law
I'm trying not to be purple because
we're incognito and we're trying to have
a real fight normal she in a
relationship with the robot and a witch
that's entangled that's a pretty complex
stuff I'm sticking to what conduct know
there's many like relationship therapist
scenes not putting these spoilers in
this is the last question it are the
fans supporters orders going to get more
vision fashion is there gonna be you
know there's a cry for a vision in the
from the previous film in sweater you
know yeah cuz I think he was trying to
instruct us well it was great yeah I
think he was trying to go for sort of
Cary Grant and now he's sort of he's
fascinators are waiting to know what
vision is like there's a little crumby
there I think um because yes while we
were making this film a lot of fun
things happened it was really nice to
peer into the process that the Avengers
have which is slightly different than
the process for the Guardians making a
film like the Avengers they just
approach it slightly differently than we
have with the guardians Robert Downey
jr. is an amazing lead and you could
tell that he was really celebrating this
film and being with the cast because he
would host these massive lunches
bad his Basecamp and invite everybody
and they would be like roasting a goat
and he'd have liked music and props and
he's like really a kind of guy who's a
champion for actors on these type of
sets and a movie like this is this
monumental you know you can kind of get
swept up in the process and end up
working so many hours to the course of
the day and Downey's have has enough
experience and wisdom that he's like no
we're gonna work as many hours and we're
gonna work ten hours and at 10:00 we're
done and like he makes sure that the
actors are really protected and that
we're joining the process and that we're
like but we totally included all of us
it was really nice and so you definitely
I feel like I learned and leveled up by
watching him because I'm thinking that's
how you should do it if you can you have
the power make the process even more
enjoyable if for the people don't work
don't work so hard stop sometime not
that he doesn't work hard but stop and
smell the roses I think it was it was
really nice way yeah I seen both of you
on screen I don't think it was too far
of a level up I think it may have done
over level but you guys you guys are
great great chemistry on screen off work
give us such enjoyment and all the films
can't wait for this one what does it
feel like to be a part of this milestone
M&C you event it I mean it feels to be a
part of something as eventful as
Avengers infinity war and having all of
these characters from different comics
come together into one plot one story
for the sake of peace was exciting it
was a ton of work but it was fun
and we really got to learn I mean III I
am and you know I feel like I also had
an opportunity for Gamora to flesh out a
little bit about her past and and
explain why she's so rigid and why she's
so reserved and and how you know we
tackled so many issues like like
relationships between parents and father
and daughters and relationships between
partners lovers friends you know and and
so we didn't we didn't shy away from
real relatable issues just because this
was a film that
get you know a sudden space with a ton
of like fictitious characters yes and
lastly some this experience up in one
word each of you one word I'm gonna use
no words I'm gonna use two emojis ghost
uses okay everyone's talking about how
there was no fun offset making this film
never it was Debbie downers always here
I I think right off the bat um Drax as
why as well as the rest of guardians and
as well as the rest of the Marvel
Universe is just a super impressed with
Thor with everywhere just in all of him
he's just like this god man we just
can't when we first meet him we're just
visually we just can't get over how
perfect use and Rex just wants to point
it out over and over and over in just
the most ridiculous ways of how handsome
and perfect this is a proportional
proportional who is the better villain
to grace the MCU stage Loki or Thanos
I mean well I've had a little more time
to to build my case I think it depends
on what bet what you class is better I
suppose
Loki I think is is accessible relatable
vulnerable charming better dressed
generally more stylish witty charismatic
and Thanos is more purple